I'm sure by now this picture is very familiar
to you. Showing you the memory hierarchy going all the
way from the CPU to the virtual memory on
the disk. You have several levels of caches, of course,
the TLB that holds address translations for you, virtual
to physical, and you have the main memory and then
the virtual memory on the disk. Now, caches are
physically tagged and so you don't need to do anything
special about them from the point of your virtualizing the
memory hierarchy. The really thorny issue is handling virtual memory, namely
the virtual address to the physical memory mapping, which is the key
functionality of the memory management subsystem in any operating system.